[موسيقى]
اتضح اخيرا غريم الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان في الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه
بعد مخاض عسير اتفقت المعارضه التركيه على
ترشيح زعيمها كمال كلش داروكلو اثر سلسله
اجتماعات ماراثونيه لزعماء تحالف الامه او
ما بات يعرف بالطاوله السداسيه
سنحكم تركيا من خلال التشاور والتوافق
اتفقنا على الانتقال الى النظام البرلماني
المعدل تم التوافق على 11 بندا بهذا
الخصوص اثناء عمليه الانتقال الى النظام
البرلماني سيكون رؤساء الاحزاب الاخرى
نوابا للرئيس الوصول الى هذا الاعلان كلف
المعارضه نزيفا في نقاطها في الشارع بعد
انسحاب زعيمه حزب الخير ميرال اكشنر من
تحالف الطاوله السداسيه احتجاجا على
ترشيحك الجدار اوغلو لمنصب الرئيس حيث دعت
لترشيح رئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم اماموجلو
او رئيس بلديه انقره منصور اواش لكن اكشنر
تراجعت عن موقفها الرافض بعد وساطات ادت
في النهايه الى التوافق على ان يكون
اماموجلو وياش نوابا للرئيس في حال ارتقى
الرئيس ذلك مع تحديد صلاح
الوثيقه نصت ايضا على منح كل حزب من
الاحزاب السته حقيبه وزاريه على الاقل اذا
لم تقوم هذه المعارضه اوراقها واستغلال
هذه الفرصه الكبيره خاصه نتحدث عن ظروف
الاقتصاديه عن كارثه زلزال فبتصور اعتقد
سوف تكون هي ورقه
ذهبيه او طبق من ذهب للرئيس اردوغان
للاستمرار في السلطه لفتره او لولايه
جديده اخرى
ومن المقرر ان تجري الانتخابات في الرابع
عشر من مايو القادم على ان يصدر اردوغان
المرسوم الخاصه بالانتخابات يوم الجمعه
المقبل
بعد زلزال هزه اركان المعارضه وانتهى
باعلان كريجدار اوغلو مرشحا مشتركا لتحالف
الطاوله السداسيه هناك من يخشى منهازات
الزلزال الارتداديه على معسكر المعارضه
نتيجه التصدعات التي خلفها انسحاب اكشنر
من التحالف ثم عودتها واللغط والجدل الذي
رافق هذا الانسحاب زيدان زنجلو العربيه
اسطنبول